You're more likely to want a default
value for type properties,
also called class properties.
You can think of class properties as
belonging more to the class itself than
to any one instance of a class because
they don't vary across objects.
A type property has the same value for
every instance of a class.
We use type properties mostly for
data we want every instance of
a class to have easy access to.
For example,
if we had a class called kids movie,
we might want to type property
called permitted ratings to keep
track of which ratings
are permissible for children.
To indicate the permitted
ratings as a type property,
we place the word static or
class in front of its definition.
Type properties are also referred to as
static properties in languages like C
and Java.
The value of this property
won't change across movies, but
it's nice to have these
ratings at our fingertips.
It'd also be nice if we had some
information about the reviews for
these movies.
Let's add an array of reviews
from different media outlets.
But then, of course,
it'd be really convenient if we could
see the average of the reviewer scores.
Let's call it a metascore,
like the app Metacritic.
Such a metascore is known
as a computed property,
a property that's computed based
on existing data in the class.
Computed properties have custom
getters and optionally custom setters.
This one doesn't really
need a setter though.
Here's our custom getter.
You probably haven't seen
this reduce function before.
It's a handy method for reducing
the values of an array to one value.
For a fun challenge, see if you can
figure out exactly what this code is
doing and post what you find
on the discussion forum.
For now, I'll just tell you that
it's returning the average of all
the scores in this array.
Let's test out our getter.
We'll initialize a movie with
some reviewer scores and
then access the metascore
using dot syntax.
Sweet!
This one ought to be a crowd-pleaser.
Now, in looking at the custom getter for
our metascore,
it may have occurred to you,
wait a second.
What about the getters and
setters for the other properties?
Guess what?
We don't have to write them.
They're automatically created
when you declare a property.